esther talks a lot about this
traumatizing time in her life when she
cut her she had to cut her hair for
the show dolphins she's in and i got
when i think back and i'm like it wasn't
that bad like
i found a picture and esther i want to
apologize i didn't validate you you
looked like
[ __ ] [ __ ] i knew it was bad i'll tell
you how i know it was bad
because jenna wrote me and said this is
bad
esther because she said oh i'm heading
over to esther's to see like her haircut
because she's having a meltdown about it
she's like i was like well no she's so
cute and no hair could possibly look
that bad
and then jenna wrote me she's like this
is really bad shaved head would have
been an improvement honestly
can i tell you what happened is there
was this this hair
the head of hair on the show hair human
who gender people
who eventually ended up being let go
from the show for other reasons which is
crazy but
she wasn't from you from her cutting no
she
she was like okay so here's we had a
meeting with all the actresses and like
okay here we're going to do this with
your hair you're going to go here you're
going to go here and she's like okay we
want to just do you give this because
it's like an america's top model when
they're doing the
hair yeah and you're like oh hopefully
i'm going to get extensions and so i
have the longest hair right i'm
so excited because this like celebrity
hairdresser is gonna she's like and i'm
gonna do yours esther and i'm like oh my
god she's doing me
little did i know like that you're a boy
that's not supposed to happen like
that's not what you want because they're
not professional hair
cutters they're they style hair so she
takes me to her house
and i'm like so excited and we're just
talking about she's telling me all the
celebrities she's worked with
and she cuts my hair and she as she's
doing it she like gets kind of weird and
then she's
and then afterwards she's like i look at
it and she's like do you like it and i'm
like what do you mean do i like it like
you're supposed to
tell me what's good it it annie said it
best i looked
it was a weird time because the michael
jackson just come out it just came out
and a documentary yeah and they would
i'm not really a joke teller though
no no i didn't say it or do you say it
i told her i was like you should go on
stage and this should be your opener you
should say
i just got my hair cut and it's a
terrible time to look both like michael
jackson and the little boys molested
it was a terrible haircut and the only
actress
the only person who was honest with me
was brenda song she was like
yeah this isn't good she's like you need
we need to get this having this told you
by
like one of the most beautiful women in
the world you're just like
i wonder what kind of person you are
though are you somebody who at that
moment says yeah this is horrible
no you walk out and you know you because
i can't personally i can never tell
somebody i hate a haircut
i walk out i've left with my hair cut
here and long hair and been like bye
[ __ ]
all my money back really yes because
well i'll tell the story when you guys
are done
no okay all right i go i'm i was in new
york and i
you ever get those like moments in your
life where you go any haircut will do
i've just been
being too precious and i'll just it's
new york like everyone's a good like so
i
i just walk by this hairstyle i'm like i
need a haircut that's typically my
approach it's my hair grows back it's
not a big deal
right and but i forget i've blacked out
all the times i've cried i've banged a
hair dryer against something you know
like
cracked the foundation that the the sink
is in and my family's house
no big deal um but just really well i'm
like no i'm i've grown up i'm out of
this
so i walk into this hair salon and
the woman working behind the counter
knows me from aaa she goes oh my god
and and i'm like oh it's like an a.a are
you allowed to do that
don't you when you see a people out in
the world yeah if you know each other
yeah yeah
you're not supposed to just ignore each
other you don't like walk away like no
you
no no you can like i wouldn't if she
went to if i was with someone she went
like oh this [ __ ] like
used to like chug butt chug jaeger or
whatever you know that's not something i
did
but it sounds fun my next relapse hey
guys wanna take a really quick break to
share some of our favorite sponsors